يتقدم الرئيس الآن بـ
18229 صوتًا في بنسلفانيا ،
ولا يزال هناك 163000 صوتًا ليتم عد
معظمها في معاقل ديمقراطية ،
حوالي 50000 منهم
هنا في مدينة فيلادلفيا
حيث يمكنك أن ترى في المنزل ،
جو بايدن يفوز بالمزيد  أكثر من 80 في
المائة من الأصوات ، ومع احتساب هذه الأصوات عبر البريد ،
فقد فاز بنسبة مئوية أعلى
لأن تذكر أن الديمقراطيين صوتوا
بشكل غير متناسب من خلال
الجمهوريين الذين تم إطلاق سراحهم بكفالة
بشكل غير متناسب في يوم الانتخابات ،
فأنت تتراجع عن هذا التقدم مرة واحدة
فوق
600000 صوت يبكي الرئيس
إنه خطأ يبكي وهو يغش ،
هذه هي الرياضيات التي تم فيها احتساب الأصوات في يوم الانتخابات
أولاً ، انظر أولاً إلى كل هذه المناطق الحمراء
في الولاية ، قام الرئيس بعمل رائع
بإخراج صوته الذي تم
احتسابه ، لقد حقق تقدمًا كبيرًا
في اختيار حالة بطاقات الاقتراع عبر البريد
أخيرًا ، لم يرغبوا في
الشعور بالارتباك في يوم الانتخابات ، لذا
تعاملوا مع ذلك أولاً
الآن وهم يعدون بطاقات الاقتراع عبر البريد
ومرة أخرى تمامًا كما في  لق
كان هذا أمرًا منهجيًا
وثابتًا في جورجيا وقد شاهدنا للتو
تقدم الرئيس يتقلص
ومرة أخرى كل التوقعات هنا هي أنه عن
ما تأتي هذه في بعض هذ
المقاطعات الأخرى هنا ، هن
ك أيضًا ما يقرب من 40000 حوالي 36000 بط
قة اقتراع يتم احتسابها  هنا في
مقاطعة بيتسبرغ ، يمكنك أن ترى أن
جو بايدن يفوز بما يقرب من 60 في المائة
من الأصوات التي تم
فرزها في مقاطعة أليغيني حتى الآن
ومرة أخرى لا أريد أن أكون رق
ًا قياسيًا مكسورًا ولكني أريد فقط أن أتأكد من ال
اس  يفهمون
في بطاقات الاقتراع بالبريد أثناء قيامهم
بحسابها أنها أعلى بشكل غير متناسب من
ذلك حتى أنها 70
تقترب غالبًا من 80 في المائة